it is december 26th and i thought that
since we were one day after christmas we
could do a little meditation on the
christmas troparion which is a hymn that
we sing in the orthodox church on every
christmas one of the main hymns and we
can look at how this hymn
shows the transformation that
christianity brings in the pagan world
the transformation it brings on the
manner in which the different gods are
perceived the way that the heavens are
perceived and how in a way it's a
continuation of the ancient world of the
ancient pagan world but it's also
a transformation of the order of it and
the way that it lays itself out
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
so the nativity troparion goes like this
your nativity o christ our god has shown
to the world the light of wisdom for by
it those who worshipped the stars were
taught by a star to adore you
son of righteousness and to know you the
orient from on high o lord glory to you
of course there are several translations
of this i'm going to use this one it's
totally fine you can find other
translations online that are completely
fine as well
even though they're different
um and so what is happening in this
troperion so of course it is referring
to the wise men to the mages
who come from the east
guided by a star in order to find christ
born in bethlehem now when they arrive
of course they don't arrive it seems
arrive when he's born in the manger in
the cave but the way it's represented in
the icon
of of the nativity will tend to unite
all those elements together into one
which is not only completely fine but
shows the the deepest aspect of this
mystery so it says that the burst birth
of christ our god which is important the
birth of god in the world
now the whole theme of the triparion is
related to light but it's not only
related to light you'll see that it's
also related to the notion of
principalities to the idea of these
beings these patterns that are up above
in the heavens that are up above us
physically as we see them but also above
us in the more uh let's say meaning
sense that is things that are higher up
in the world that are more important
that uh show
the meaning of other things that are
below it um
and so the whole theme is about is is
bound light so it's related also to
creation to the idea of the manner in
which creation is described in scripture
as uh especially in the the first
chapter of john as related to light um
but it all kind of comes together in the
and so
the birth of christ or god has shown the
world the light of wisdom and so when we
talk about the light of wisdom we're
obviously relating meaning
the highest form of meaning and the most
incarnate form of meaning with light
itself and so by this incarnation
those who worship the stars
were now taught by a star to worship you
to adore you
and so the the people who worship the
stars now in order to totally understand
this triparian what you need to
understand is that in the old testament
but not only in the old testament in
ancient cultures there's a direct
relationship between the stars and the
gods there is a relationship between the
stars and the angels we see that in the
old testament where the word for the
stars and the word for the council the
divine council
the beings that that are around god that
serve god in the heavens they are the
same words and so this is the
transformation that christianity is
bringing that is
the people before the the arrival of
christ they saw the patterns up in the
heavens they saw the beings up in the
heavens uh both physically they could
see the patterns of the stars which were
regular and those regular patterns could
map on to our more kind of chaotic world
of course everybody makes fun of
astrology but there is a manner in which
astrology or basic astrology is there's
absolutely nothing strange about it or
weird or surprising there's a basic
astrology which is that when we look at
the world below like if i'm looking at a
apple rotting on the ground
it is very chaotic and it depends on the
elements it depends on if it's wet or if
it's dry depends on if there are flies
in it if they're worms all of this other
stuff that's below is is messier let's
say
um and when we look above what we see
are the regular patterns those regular
patterns
the transformation of the different
amount of light that goes through the
year the waxing and waning of the moon
and also the procession of the heavenly
bodies in the sky
are
regular that is they they change we can
we can calculate them we can map them we
can know when these things changes and
we can predict when they're going to
happen ex very very precisely more
precisely than most of the patterns that
you kind of see
down here below it's like it's like a
clock it's like this giant clock by
which now our lives and our
our days are managed by this clock so
the way that the light moves in the sky
actually manages your day right that it
tells you when you're awake it tells you
when you're sleeping you know it tells
you what you can do and it also is
related to the season so when certain
things above are happening you know it's
cold you know it's warm you know it's
time to plant you know it's time to do
the different things you do now of
course today
because we live in a world of technology
we're a little abstracted from these
patterns but you have to understand that
in the ancient world the people lived by
these patterns the heavenly patterns you
could say it
related to the idea of the heavenly
spheres if you think of the
pythagorean description when it says
that the spheres of heaven are making
music
the spheres of heaven are making this
music that only the initiated only the
very wise can hear now we tend to think
of it in a very materialistic way but
music just means patterns right that is
that the spheres of heaven have patterns
regular patterns which
um
are related to our lives and are related
to the how we organize our life maybe
think of it think of it that way that
the heavenly patterns are related to the
way we organize our life to the way we
give meaning and structure and direction
to our lives down here below now this of
course
is is the way in which the ancient
people would interact with these
heavenly bodies now of course in the
idea that we present here and that also
is presented in the lord of spirits is
that at some point people started to
worship these heavenly patterns they
started to see them as absolute now
there are many heavenly patterns and of
course there are the heavy bodies above
but there are also heavenly patterns in
the sense that there are patterns of
being so there are certain patterns that
manage let's say war there are certain
patterns that manage certain cities
there are certain patterns that matter
manage different aspects of reality love
desire um you know and and all the
natural patterns and so people started
to see them and started to worship them
um and this is what we could call the
fall of the angels or the fall of the
gods
no matter where you see it happening in
the story there's a sense in which at
some point these patterns started to ask
worship for themselves and this
coincides of course when people started
to give
worship to those patterns you can always
see it bottom up or top down it doesn't
matter how you represent it it's the
same really
and so you can it's what what
christianity does and what christ does
is he reorganizes this into the right
the right pattern the right order where
it is that those that worship the stars
are now taught by those very star by a
star to worship you
the son of righteousness that is the
brightest light in the heaven the the
light of heaven which is the one by
which we manage all our
existence the king of heaven you could
say and so you can see this right in
in the old testament where the sun is
placed as the king of heaven and now
it's the not just the sun the physical
sun but it's the sun of righteousness
that is the heavenly patterns are
connected to meaning just like they were
at the beginning when it says the the
your nativity has shown the world the
light of wisdom now it's the light of
righteousness so it's connecting these
heavenly bodies with
the the human experience or the human
place of meaning and of morality and of
human interaction
and so now the the star that the
the star that the um
the wise men followed
taught them to worship the
origin of light the source of light the
son of righteousness and to know you
the east
from on high that is
the analogy of the east
in the world that is the source of light
which comes up in the morning but now
from above the higher version of that
the higher version of the source of
light
and then oh lord glory to you now
the troparion is doing very amazing
things it's doing what it says that the
light did for them
that is the triparian itself is talking
about how the following of the star and
the encountering of christ reordered
their world
first
in order in relationship to
let's say uh reordering it towards the
idea of the the
brightest light as being the most
important light but it reordered that
their word towards meaning that it
reordered the heavenly patterns
the that you see above towards the
higher meanings which are the moral
meanings which are the the meanings of
our existence the meaning of how we
exist together and how we exist facing
this highest meaning so this is what the
the happened to the
the wise men to the magi but it's also
what's happening in the song itself in
the the song itself is doing that in its
structure by using the heavenly patterns
and at every almost at every line
pointing that heavenly pattern towards a
spiritual pattern towards a high pattern
in the sense of morality in the sense of
spirituality and in the sense of meaning
now
this of course is what christianity does
and you see once you realize that that's
what christianity does you also realize
that it's already there in the story of
christmas it's already there the
treparion is only showing us that
uh something which is already there in
the the story at the outset and so
think now of the angels and the the
shepherds now the story of the angels
and the shepherds is the same as the
story of the magi and the star remember
i told you at the outset that the the
star
and the angels or the gods above
in the ancient world were seen as the
same
and so the magi see this star above
which is moving in a manner pointing
them to the incarnation
the
now the shepherds they see in the
heavens
the patterns of heaven that's what
they're they have an experience of the
patterns of heaven which is the
experience of the angels singing the
what the magi experience
the the pattern of heaven pointing them
towards the incarnation and with the
with the shepherds experience that is
the the the heavenly sphere is singing
for them
the heavenly uh beings singing for them
those two things are the same in terms
of what they are helping you understand
of what is going on in the incarnation
and this is of course what christianity
does this is of course the true
transformation which happens in
christianity which is that christianity
doesn't
deny the existence of the intermediary
beings doesn't deny the
the patterns above doesn't deny the
existence of principalities and thrones
and all of these
all of these beings that are in between
us and god but rather it conquers them
in the powerful way or it transforms
them in a way that makes them not only
these things which are competing with
god and are trying to get our worship
like our passions like all the different
interests that we have but is able to
reorder them so that now these
principalities now these angels that are
between us and god whether it be this
whether it be your different uh capacity
to pay attention to different things
whether it be the saints whether it be
you know you're the king or all these
principalities that are
between us and and god they're able to
reorient them so that they show us
the higher
pattern
so think of it like it's not that you
worship your father as god but that
encountering your father in the proper
way will help you understand something
about god and the way that god rules
over you the way that god loves you you
can see now through the pattern of your
physical father and so you can see the
same with the king and so when you un
when you interact with the king when you
interact with civil authorities there's
some if they're properly ordered what
they can do is they can point you up to
the higher patterns they can point you
up through the the small amount of light
that they have can point you now up to
the sun of righteousness the origin of
all light and of all meaning in the
world and so this is something that
we've also of course been insisting on
very much in the past year i would say
both myself and of course the lord of
spirits podcast which is to help
understand that especially now today as
we're as we're noticing the modern world
and the modern kind of uh monolithic
thinking break down as we see these
principalities re-emerge and kind of
reappear in the world we're capable of
seeing them capable of interacting them
interacting with them we have to
understand that
one of the things that christ does that
the incarnation does is that it's able
to help us interact with them in a
healthy way in a way that points to the
highest but if we're not careful if we
especially as the world moves away from
christianity what we're going to see is
we're going to see these lights these
stars these patterns uh reimpose
themselves in for themselves we're going
to see pagan practices we're going to
see all of this stuff kind of come back
where the competing principalities the
competing gods will start to fight
amongst each other and of course that
will reflect itself in the world as
groups and as people fight amongst each
other as well and of course there'll
also be a
an overcompensation by the authorities
to try to get that power for themselves
right to to
fight the different principalities and
try to gather the power in the state or
gather the power in some a few
monolithic structures that will try to
impose themselves
and so i was hoping that this could
maybe
give you a little bit of uh of a of
magic for christmas and a little bit of
a perception of how powerful these
stories are even though we're used to
them even though we're used to hearing
them how they are really not just about
uh a young a boy that was born in
bethlehem 2000 years ago but they really
are about the reordering of the very
cosmos both in the scripture itself but
then also in the way that we celebrate
it for example in the christmas
treparion so i wish everybody a merry
christmas christ is born glorify him and
i will talk to you very soon